[Music]
Final Fantasy 15 has shipped more than
six million copies since its launch last
year and now publisher Square Enix is
hoping fans will help it shape the
game's future by filling out a survey
I'm Matt this is a game spot news update
and make sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more coverage of spiky haired teens
saving the world the survey has a total
of twenty-four questions kicking things
off with the basics like your age gender
and whether you've played Final Fantasy
15 or not this first part of the survey
is pretty straightforward but starts to
get more substantial as you get closer
to the end it eventually asks for your
opinion on season passes and DLC and the
final question well that gives you the
chance to ask the Final Fantasy 15 team
one thing and I can only imagine what
some of those questions might be
speaking of DLC Final Fantasy 15 is set
to receive a new hat in the shape of a
cup noodle square enix is teaming up
with noodle company neeson for 15
different types of noodles and if you
buy the food you get a code that unlocks
the goofy hat it sounds like this is
only available in Japan but we'll report
back if anything similar it gets
announced for the West for now check out
our dance pot universe channel where we
cover all the movies TV and anime you
could possibly want